generation is the next major sonic
action game it's coming out on ps3 and
360 in holiday 2011 and it's created as
a celebration of the fact that this year
is Sonic's 20th anniversary 20 years
since the release a sonic one on the
Genesis I think it really will be a
great game for people who have fond
memories of Sonic back in the Genesis
era to come back to all the stages in
the game are based on past stages from
rubber Sonic titles we have stages from
the Genesis days we have stages from
Dreamcast era and we have stages from
current generation they're all
reimagined redesigned levels so even if
you played those levels before they're
in that environment but it's a new level
in Zion so it's an experience the other
major feature is the fact that there are
two type of game file there's a modern
sonic gameplay which means of gameplay
scene at sonic colours and so I
unleashed the other style of gameplay is
what I think laps players will be most
excited about which is we're bringing
back classic sonic gameplay so it's the
first time that we're trying to recreate
you know to the Genesis platformer with
momentum based platform so basically it
goes back to the old design philosophy
of the Genesis games more speed is a
reward and there are multi-tiered to
welcome to your level design that
basically the higher that you go the
more difficult it is to stay up there
but the more rewards that you get which
you know open the levels up to a lot of
exploration but also makes it a lot of
fun for players of various skill levels